VOICES UNSETTLING.
>> GOING TO PUT THE EARPHONES IN
AND DO A SERIES OF TESTS.
OKAY.
SO I'M NOW HEARING SORT OF
WHISPERS AND VOICES IN MY HEAD
AND IT'S NUMBER PUZZLES.
>> LISTEN.
>> YOU SUCK AND THEY KNOW IT!
CAN'T YOU GET THIS RIGHT?
>> OKAY.
SO I DID THIS TEST FOR THREE
MINUTES AND I DID NOT GET A
SINGLE ONE.
IT'S VERY HARD TO -- IT'S HARD
TO CONCENTRATE WHEN IF IT'S
MUSIC OR SOMETHING CONSTANT,
IT'S EASY BUT PEOPLE TALKING TO
YOU IS VERY DIFFICULT.
SO NOW I'M GOING TO BE ASKED A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS BY OUR
PRODUCER SUSAN AND THESE ARE
BASICALLY A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
THAT A PERSON WOULD BE ASKED AND
THEY WERE ADMITTED TO A
HOSPITAL.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT DAY IT
IS?
>> YEAH.
IT'S SUNDAY, JUNE -- I DON'T
KNOW.
WHAT'S THE DATE?
THE 7th?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY FIVE NUMBERS
AND REPEAT THEM BACK.
>> OKAY.
>> FIVE, 23, 67, 2, 76.
>> ALMOST THERE.
>> 5, 23, 67, SOMETHING, 76.
>> ENOUGH MEAT.
>> FIVE WORDS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REPEAT THEM.
BUT JUST LISTEN TO THEM.
>> YOU'LL BE ME.
>> CAT.
BOOK.
>> TO ME.
>> CIGAR.
>> I'LL MAKE IT.
>> DAMAGE AND RAIN.
>> MAKE YOU OKAY.
>> CAN YOU NAME THE LAST FOUR
PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> OKAY FOR YOU TO BE --
>> BARACK OBAMA, GEORGE BUSH.
>> RIGHT HERE.
>> BILL CLINTON.
GEORGE BUSH.
>> SO THOSE FIVE WORDS I SAID
BEFORE, CAN YOU REMEMBER ANY OF
THEM?
>> NO.
IT'S HARD WHEN -- BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THE VOICES ARE
WHISPERING.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE AGGRESSIVE AND
SOMETIMES KIND OF COMFORTING
AND, AGAIN, WITH PEOPLE TALKING
TO YOU ALL THE TIME, IT'S --
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> IT'S HARD.
>> DON'T WORRY.
NOW OR LATER.
DON'T WORRY.
>> TRYING TO MAKE A BOAT,
ORIGAMI FOLLOWING THESE
INSTRUCTIONS.
>> IT WILL BE OKAY.
NEAR, NEAR.
GET NEAR.
>> SHUT UP!
SHUT UP!
>> I WANT TO TALK BACK TO THE
VOICES NOW BUT IT'S REALLY
DISTRACTING.
>> NOT DO IT!
DO NOT TOUCH THAT!
STOP!
>> EYES DOWN.
>> YOU SUCK!
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
THIS IS EASY!
YOU WANT TO TOUCH THAT?
>> I CAN'T DO THIS.
>> HAND DOWN.
KEEP YOUR EYES DOWN.
JUST DO IT.
NO.
FILTHY MIND!
LEAVE IT ALONE!
>> IT'S ALSO FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
THEY'RE TELLING ME I CAN'T DO IT
AND I'M -- I DIDN'T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB WITH THE BOAT BUT IT'S
REALLY HARD TO FOCUS WHEN KIND
OF PEOPLE ARE WHISPERING TO YOU
AND TALKING TO YOU.
>> JUST COME CLEAR.
COME NEAR TO ME.
COME NEAR FOR HELP.
>> HEY.
DO YOU HAVE YESTERDAY'S PAPER?
YESTERDAY'S "THE NEW YORK
TIMES"?
NO?
OKAY.
I'LL JUST GET TODAY'S.
IT'S REALLY -- IT'S INCREDIBLY
DISTRA
DISTRACTING HAVING SOMEBODY
TALKING IN YOUR HEAD AND MAKES
YOU FEEL COMPLETELY ISOLATED AND
FIND YOURSELF WANTING TO ENGAGE
IN CONVERSATION WITH THE VOICES
IN THE HEAD AN THEY'RE NEGATIVE
AND TALKING TO YOU AND
EVERYTHING THEY'RE SAYING
RELATES TO THINGS YOU'RE DOING,
CRITICIZING THINGS YOU'RE DOING.
LIKE SOMEBODY'S -- LIKE YOU HAVE
A CHORUS WATCHING YOU AND
COMMENTING ON WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND YOU CAN'T HELP BUT -- I MEAN
I LITERALLY FIND MYSELF WANTING
TO RESPOND TO THEM, KIND OF TELL
THEM TO BE QUIET AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY UNPLEASANT.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY UNPLEASANT
EXPERIMENT.
IT'S REALLY -- IT'S EYE OPENING
BECAUSE IT KIND OF REALLY SHOWS
YOU WHAT IT'S -- WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE MUST BE GOING THROUGH WHO
DEAL WITH THIS ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
BUT ALSO, LIKE I CANNOT WAIT TO
TAKE THESE HOLD PHONES OFF
BECAUSE IT'S -- IT'S REALLY
DEPRESSING.
IT'S VERY -- IT'S VERY NEGATIVE.
IT MAKES YOU FEEL VERY, VERY
NEGATIVE.
YEAH.
IT'S VERY CREEPY.
I WANT IT TO STOP.
>> EYES DOWN.
BACK UP.
STAND UP NOW!
I'LL CUT YOU OFF.
I'VE CUT 20, 30, 40.
>> YOU'RE OKAY.
>> WALK NOW.
>> YES.
>>